وقع الزلزال وكان وقعه كبيرا على سوريا
وتركيا مع اعداد الضحايا الكبيره في
الدولتين تركيا شكلت لجنه لتحقيق في جرائم
الزلزال من وفيات واصابات والمتهمون
مقاولون ومهندسون الاوضاع في تركيا اختلط
فيها الانساني بالسياسي خاصه مع اقتراب
الانتخابات الرئاسيه والبرلمانيه في مايو
المقبل المعارضه قالت ان حمله الاعتقالات
التي طالت المقاولين تغافلت عما اسمتهم
بالمسؤولين الاساسيين عن الكارثه وهم
المطورون المتنفذون والمرتبطون بكبار
المسؤولين منتقده في الوقت نفسه الاستجابه
الحكوميه البطيئه كما وصفتها بعد حدوث
الزلزال زعيم حزب الشعب الجمهوري المعارض
كمال كليتش دار اوغلو قال ان الحكومه حولت
المنازل الى قبور من خلال العفو عن
المباني
خلافا للمواصفات الزلزال وقانون العفو
لعام 2018 قضيه سياسيه رئيسيه في تركيا
قبل ثلاثه اشهر فقط من الانتخابات العامه
لكن ما هو هذا القانون قانون العفو هذا
البرنامج اقر قبل خمسه اعوام وقنن اوضاع
ملايين المباني منها الكثير التي خالفت
معايير الابنيه المقاومه للزلزال او
الزلازل بطبيعه الحال صحيفه قالت ان
الحكومه التركيه تواجه رد فعل عنيف متزايد
خاصه وان القانون اسفر عن اخطاء في ملايين
المباني في جميع انحاء تركيا وبشكل او
باخر ادى لانتشار ممارسات البناء السيئه
التي كشفها زلزال الاسبوع الماضي اشارت
الصحيفه الى ان السلطات التركيه وافقت على
سبعه ملايين و400 الف طلب لتقنين اوضاع
خلال اول عام ونصف من صدور هذا القانون مع
اخضاع المطورين والمقاولين لرسوم مقابل ان
يشملهم القانون وحينها جمعت السلطات نحو
اربعه مليارات و200 مليون دولار كرسوم
تسجيل المباني وفقا لوزاره البيئه التركيه
واسرد جورنال التقت بمختصين في التخطيط
الحضري وقالوا ان النطاق الواسع للقانون
ينطبق على كل شيء تقريبا بني بشكل مخالف
للمطلوب وانه اعطى اشاره للمقاولين بان
المباني غير القانونيه سيتم تقنينها في
نهايه المطاف بغض النظر عن مواصفات البناء
وكانت التقديرات الرسميه الاخيره اشارت
الى ان حوالي نصف المباني في تركيا او
ثلاثه عشر مليون مبنى لا تمتثل للمعايير
وفقا لوزاره البيئه التركيه
[موسيقى]